du jamais vu au Brésil ou ailleurs le
président réfugié dans son palais de
l'alvorada dans la capitale Brasilia qui
refuse de dire quoi que ce soit au
vainqueur Louis ignaccio Lula da Silva
sans donner le moindre indice de ce
qu'il compte faire malgré la pression de
ces ministres et de ses conseillers deux
jours de réflexion pour deux petites
minutes dans lesquelles il ne reconnaît
pas le résultat mais une petite phrase
est clée
à me conformer à tous les commandements
de notre Constitution or après une
élection en bonnet du forme que personne
ne conteste la Constitution prévoit une
transition et la passation des pouvoirs
le 1er janvier il en attribue la tâche à
son chef de cabinet
le président m'a autorisé à entamer sur
la base de la loi le processus de
transition
mais Jaïr bolsonaro sans parler de
fraude critique encore le système
électoral en disant que les
manifestations actuelles traduisent bien
le fait qu'il est injuste mais elle ne
doivent pas troubler l'ordre public
adjectif
simple
donc il n'appuie pas le blocage des
routes du Brésil déclenchées depuis les
résultats de l'élection par ses
partisans
presque tous les États sont touchés en
particulier celui de San Paolo artère
congestionné l'aéroport international de
guarillos paralysée des centaines de
vols annulés les routes pour le Brésil
sont le seul moyen de transport des
marchandises et des dents répétables
personne n'a pu les camionneurs qui
bloquent les routes sauf peut-être la
police fédérale de la route elle-même
qui compte beaucoup de partisans de
bolsonaro et qui ont visiblement laissé
faire
les tribunaux ont confirmé que les
blocus étaient illégaux les participants
seront frappés de fortes amendes et
toutes les polices ont été mobilisées
pour dégager les routes avec cette
courte allocution la crise
constitutionnelle semble désamorcée il
n'y aura pas de contestation de
l'élection celle des camionneurs
devraient l'être aussi si la police
parvient à dégager les routes demain
c'est férié ici c'est la fête des morts
les Brésiliens devraient se sentir
soulagés Jean-Michel Leprince
Radio-Canada et aux généraux